Oh
researchers at Columbia University have
discovered that blocking serotonin a
hormone that affects mood could lead to
a medical treatment for osteoporosis
it's a brand new pathway a new blend new
way to treat osteoporosis by including
bone formation two years ago Gerard
karsenty and his team at Columbia
University Medical Center made a
startling discovery they showed that
serotonin which is found in the gut as
well as the brain plays an active role
in the formation of bones so we
hypothesize that if we could invite
inhibit those entities of civil Tony
means of stomach we could have an oval
with anabolic treatment for osteoporosis
luckily a drug being tested in people
with irritable bowel syndrome could do
the job karsenty and his team fed the
same drug to my suffering from
osteoporosis and found that the drug
increased the animals bone mass and
erased audience of the disease when we
realized that the compound could reverse
completely and osteoporosis in mice
without side effect we were particularly
pleased to see the list to measure bone
loss Carson tease team harvested mouse
bones and embedded them in a plastic
resin then they made very thin cross
sections of the vertebrae and long bones
for viewing under a microscope the
researchers examined the bone density by
comparing the amounts of rigid bone and
marrow which each appear as a different
color removals a ratio of black / pink
because black is bone and think of
pinkish is bone marrow computer software
then measured whether the mice that
received the drug had thicker bones
indeed the drug increased the number of
bone forming cells to make treated mice
appear perfectly normal but the bones of
mice that did not get the drug looked as
fragile as those found in people with
osteoporosis the next step is to see if
the drug also works in humans so it's
very difficult to state now that this
will be a treatment for osteoporosis in
on because we have not tested it but it
is reasonable to test it at least and if
the drug works in humans it could be a
brand new way to treat a disease that
afflicts millions of people around the
world for nature medicine I'm a lead
organ
you